hi there steve kaufman here again and
today i'm going to talk about language
immersion
if you enjoy these videos on language
learning please subscribe
and also i remind you that for those of
you who are not native speakers this
video the audio the transcript can be
studied at link and i'm going to leave a
link link
in the description box so you can study
this to improve your english i think we
all know that language immersion
is an ideal way to improve in a language
what do we mean by language immersion
obviously it means being immersed in the
language in other words hearing the
language reading the language speaking
the language being you know covered head
to foot so to speak if we think of the
analogy with swimming or being immersed
in water language immersion is being
immersed in the language now this is
normally it can be the situation if you
live where the language is spoken if you
live surrounded by the language you're
immersed in the language
now being where the language is spoken
is no guarantee
that in others you may in fact be
immersed immersed in the language
potentially you're in a language
immersion situation but don't take
advantage of it and we have many
examples here in canada for example of
immigrants who live here for many years
and don't improve in english because
they don't take advantage of that
environment so it's no guarantee
and and part of the reason why they
don't is because let's face it it's not
that easy you do have to have a strategy
you do have to prepare yourself you
can't just go there and expect somehow
by magic that you're going to pick up
the language when i went to japan i
didn't go to school but i learned japan
and japanese i spent a lot of time
listening and reading and building up my
vocabulary so that i can i could
understand what what people were saying
so that i could interact with them so
you still have to have a strategy even
if you are immersed in the language
now if you are not where the language is
spoken then i think you could have a
kind of a related strategy which is what
i do like right now i'm working on
polish and i would like one day to go to
poland
i hope i do go i don't know when i will
go but i have that as a goal to
eventually put myself in a situation
where i will be immersed i'll be
experiencing language immersion so i
spend a lot of time
reading on the internet i use that link
i use our link chrome extension to
quickly import articles from polish
newspapers
while maintaining my ukrainian and
russian
and i listen and once a week or so i may
speak in other words i'm preparing
myself
with the thought that one day i will be
in that language immersion environment
and i'll be you know ready to hit the
ground running so you do need to have a
strategy whether you're in that
immersion environment or whether you're
trying to create an artificial immersion
environment and and of course that's
much easier to do today than it ever was
in the past
also when i think of language immersion
i think of french immersion
uh here in canada where
anglophone students
study or do most of their in fact all of
their schooling for the first seven
eight nine years in french and then by
grade 10 and 11 it tapers off a bit but
at least half their subjects are in
french even in those final years
and apparently because i have three
grandchildren who went through the
program uh the first six seven years or
so the kids do speak to each other in
french and then they are less and less
inclined to do so so that the immersion
experience becomes less of a full
language immersion experience
also
they read in class but they don't have
any handy tools to make that reading
easier for them and it is hard to read
on science or history or whatever it
might be math in another language so i
think that link
would be very useful in this immersion
environment because it adds another
dimension so they're not just reading
they can listen to the text they can
save words and phrases
and also i think the audio helps give
you some momentum
because i've always especially when i
was younger reading in french as a 17
year old was more difficult but if you
have the audio if you can easily look up
new words and see the words that you
previously looked up and so forth it
just gives you more momentum and makes
it a more complete language immersion
experience in my view anyway those are
my views on language immersion and i
look forward to your thoughts
bye for now